Obama tells Democrats to get over their
obsession with Trump the thing that I I
think sometimes we seem to make a
mistake on is his behavior can be so
outrageous and now folks who try to copy
him and his outrageous behavior are
getting a lot of attention Obama said
referring to Maga supporters and so we
join that game and we spend enormous
amount of time and energy resources
pointing out the labely the latest crazy
thing that he said or how rude or mean
of these Republican candidates behaved
that's probably not something that in
the minds of most voters overrides their
basic interests can I pay the rent what
are the gas price what are gas prices
how am I dealing with child care Obama
continued so it's it what's what's the
reason why Obama is now saying this
today is it because midterms is less
than a few weeks away is it because you
know oh you know they're he's just kind
of watching people seeing how they're
losing control and it's worried how bad
things are going to be why do you think
he made the comments that he made can I
ask you a question yeah for you
um what do you think that the Biden
White House thought about these comments
no we don't want to talk about the
economy what are you doing
do you think the Biden White House and
the strategist appreciated the
ex-president saying not only that but
saying it when he say do you think maybe
deep down inside he wants Biden to break
his record you know what his record is
right most seats flipped 61 he's like
dude that's not a record I want to hold
it's like having the most strikeouts in
a season it's like look man I want you
to take that strikeout record away from
me all I'm looking for Biden is for you
to flip 62. okay to lose 62 and I'm
happy where I don't have to have that
record but why do you think you made the
comments that he made today three weeks
out two weeks out did he use Trump by
name did he actually did he say try I
don't know that's not Obama's style he
might allude to somebody I don't know if
he actually used Trump's name obviously
we know who he's referencing is when you
use terms like outrageous and crazy rude
and mean we know who he's talking about
uh however I don't know if he actually
addressed Trump what's your point though
but I do have a a I'm wondering if he
uses no he didn't he didn't use his name
so yeah that's check one number two I
kind of agree with Obama to hear about
the time and the energy
Jesus and I fell victim to this how much
time and energy you spent to following
up what the hell Trump said that day or
that week or that tweet
Jesus it took a lot of energy and time
for everybody whether you're defending
him and no that's not what he meant and
dear you're misinterpreting what he said
and good people on both like time and
energy and if you're one of the people
that were on the other side of the the
Maga you know side of things just the
the obsession that you paid attention to
all the ridiculous things that you lost
nights of sleep over this man and I know
there are not a ton of amazing things
that you can say about Biden
but one of those things is he's not
making ridiculous news that you can
actually move on with your life and
spend your time and energy on things
that you can control your own money your
own pocketbook your kitchen table issues
your family your health
so everything comes with the pro and a
con everything's binary but I do agree
that people spend a lot of time and
energy focusing on Trump
do you have any thoughts on this or I
just think Trump was the counter swing
of Obama so it's It's Always Rings false
to me when Obama is talking about Trump
because quite honestly I think Obama's
policies led to Trump in a lot of ways
so you know we're on the same page I
think he gave birth to Trump he did
that's simple yeah I think Bush gave
birth to a birth to Obama and I think
Obama gave birth to
Trump I've got an analogy doing some
journaling and I was thinking about this
you know America's political system in a
lot of ways is like you know a pendulum
is one of those things we take and the
ball goes and then it slowly stabilizes
our the American democracy was a
pendulum that started in the middle and
is like slowly slowing one way and it
goes back the other way and like we're
at a place now where it's like violently
swinging from side to side and you know
that is the Obama Trump swing and in you
know back to Biden it's just uh I'm
hoping we can get some leadership that
can stabilize it and not have these
violent swings fully agree we've used
that pendulum analogy a ton of times and
I mean how do you go from Obama to Trump
to all the way back to Obama's number
two Biden just because
it's crazy
consulate pendulum swinging and I've
said it before I said it again I would
love whether to santis whether it's any
anyone else get to a somehow a 60
approval rating yeah every our last
presidents have been hovering below 50
for the better part of five ten years
now if not longer
um and
we need a UniFi or not I'm vegetator I
want to do so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]